[Music]
on this tuesday night conflicting advice
about covid vaccines
should i have read it is there really a
preferred vaccine we answer the question
so many canadians are asking as
provinces consider whether to mix
and match the second doses i don't think
there's anything intrinsically unsafe
plus as case counts soar alberta's
premier plans tighter restrictions
tragedy in mexico city
what caused the deadly collapse of a
subway train platform
and the race to find survivors and two
friends who took matters into their own
hands
i asked myself you know like how hard
would it be
to actually build something like this
the new texting tool connecting
canadians
with vaccines
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we want to try to clarify the public
health messaging about covid19 vaccines
for months we have repeated the advice
to take the first vaccine you were
offered
then the national advisory committee on
immunization a group of physicians and
vaccine experts
muddled that message it says the pfizer
and moderna vaccines both of them mrna
vaccines are
preferred over astrazeneca and johnson
and johnson
well here are some undisputed facts
first every piece of evidence we have
now points to vaccines as the way out of
the pandemic
four vaccines are approved for use here
in canada all
will prevent you from getting seriously
ill or dying from covet 19.
millions of doses have been given to
people in countries around the world
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine does
carry an exceedingly rare risk of
developing blood clots believed to be
roughly one in one hundred thousand
but the risk of developing blood clots
from covid19
is much higher than that today prime
minister justin trudeau who himself got
the astrazeneca shot
didn't criticize the experts at nasi but
he did try to get the messaging
back on track the impact
of catching kovid are far greater
and far deadlier as we've seen across
the country
than potential side effects the reality
is
the way we get through this pandemic
is to get vaccinated with whatever
vaccine is offered to us
as quickly as possible that message is
especially important if you live in part
of the country where covid19
is spreading through the community in
the middle of a third wave
vaccine shopping is a luxury those at
high risk of covid
cannot afford david aiken has our top
story tonight
when it was their turn to get the jab
the prime minister and his wife got
doses of the astrazeneca vaccine
they joined 1.7 million canadians
who've had at least one dose of
astrazeneca
on a personal level i am extremely
pleased that i got the astrazeneca
vaccine
a number of weeks ago like the trudeau's
edmonton mom
shauna pilgrim has also received a first
dose of astrazeneca
my sister works in public health and she
has been
overrun this whole time so i thought
okay i'm gonna
do my part to lessen the load for
someone like her
but with the national advisory committee
on immunization
repeating their recommendation that
pfizer and moderna the two mrna vaccines
are preferred over astrazeneca well
pilgrim is wondering what to make of
that to hear that i'm thinking
well is astrazeneca bad now like should
i have waited
so it's just very confusing to hear that
today the message from canada's chief
public health officer
don't be confused that was the right
decision the astrozenica vaccine
has really saved lives and that the
vaccine has done
what it was designed to do now millions
more
pfizer and modern vaccines are flooding
into the country and so
the situation in specific regions may
influence advice
from local officials i still encourage
everybody
to receive the vaccine that is available
to you first
and i can say that my family members
receive the astrazeneca vaccine
all our vaccines are good vaccines the
reality is that the mr
mrna vaccines are better vaccines but
the bottom line from the pm
the most important thing is to get
vaccinated
with the first vaccinate vaccine offered
to you it is how we get through this
every vaccine for use in canada has been
judged safe and effective by health
canada
now most astrazeneca vaccination
programs in the country are running low
on supply
but the federal government today says
they expect as many as
2 million more doses of astrazeneca
to be in the country by june donna okay
david aiken in ottawa thank you
well the bulk of the doses that have
arrived in canada so far
are moderna and pfizer and more of them
are on the way the federal government
says moderna is sending about one
million doses a week
earlier than planned this is the largest
modern delivery yet
it's expected to arrive tomorrow morning
combined with pfizer shipments canada is
set to receive about 3 million doses
this week as of today 34 of canadians
have had at least
one dose that's about 13 million people
only about
three percent of the population though
has been fully vaccinated with
both doses getting that second dose
means a long wait
there's some speculation the four-month
delay between first and second doses
could be shortened if enough vaccines
come into the country
but for now everyone waits and now there
is talk your second dose
may not be the same kind of vaccine as
the first
abigail beeman explains what we know and
don't know
about that the prime minister is saying
get the first vaccines available to you
so i thought i was doing
whatever i could to help myself and the
community raheb zadie was excited to get
his first shot of astrazeneca but
following
more blood clot news and confusing nasty
messaging he may not get his second
i'm strongly considering getting an mrna
vaccine as my second dose
while countries including germany france
finland and the uk have already
recommended that in some circumstances
canadians are still waiting i don't
think there's anything intrinsically
unsafe about
using two different vaccines to get an
immune response
currently nassey's advice is not to mix
provinces are calling for updated
guidance by mid-may
there is a high probability that it will
be possible but we will just see
what is going to be the response we are
also watching very carefully
what we call the mix and match studies
that are going on around the world
including a major study in the uk with
early results expected in the next few
months
these mixed schedules might well be the
key to getting two doses into as many
people
in the world as possible mixing doses
could be incredibly helpful to a country
like canada that has struggled with
supply
there is also early data showing it
could result in better immunity
each vaccine subtly stimulates part of
the immune system that's a little
different from the other one
but of course it's complicated with
astrazeneca and johnson and johnson
traditional viral vector vaccines
compared to the mrna
moderna and pfizer there's going to be
less of a difference
if you mix pfizer and moderna which
essentially produce
the same exact spike protein with very
very few differences
that's going to be a lot different than
mixing and matching entire vaccine
technologies
there will be further clarification and
advice
prior to individuals getting the second
dose
and that we should watch that space
last week spain became the first
european country to join us in a 16-week
interval between doses
in part so they could buy more time to
investigate whether
mixing vaccines is safe abigail beeman
global news
ottawa the province that leads the
country in active covid19
infections right now per capita is
putting in new public health
restrictions
alberta's premier who has been
criticized for waiting too long to act
went a step further tonight in an
address to the province jason kenney
announced new measures including
moving schools to online learning and
closing outdoor patios
governments must not uh impair people's
rights or their livelihoods
unless it is absolutely necessary to
save lives
and in this case to present disaster
from unfolding in our hospitals
with me from calgary is global news
reporter krista dao krista the premier
wanted to speak directly to albertans
what was his message
well donna has messaged to albertans
that everyone has a role to play and
that these
new measures are required to save lives
and avoid that disaster in the hospital
now the premier just wrapping up
that televised event just moments ago
and he says
these strict new measures are in place
and they will help bend
down the curve now the premier says
these new measures will prevent that
disaster in the hospital as alberta sees
rising covered 19 numbers and rising
hospitalization numbers as well
now if exponential growth of covet 19 in
alberta continues
it would begin to push the outer limits
of even our surged and expanded hospital
capacity
within weeks so let me be
clear we will not permit our health care
system to be overwhelmed
we must not and we will not force our
doctors
and nurses to decide who gets care
and who doesn't and that is why we
must act now to stop the spike
donna the biggest change is the schools
will be closing from kindergarten
to grade 12. and they will be closing
for two weeks
as well hair nail salons will also be
closed
and retailers can operate but they must
be operating
at 10 percent capacity now restaurants
will be limited to just takeout as dinen
will be closed the previous restrictions
did allow for patios to be open
so that will no longer be be happening
rather but this comes as dozens of
doctors penned a letter to the premier
calling
for these tough new measures the concern
they have
is that hospital rooms will get to a
point
where there will not be adequate care
now the premier
is also saying that there will be limits
on gatherings funerals
and places of worship now also as we've
seen
many albertans flowering these health
restrictions
the premier announced that anyone who is
in violation of these rules well those
fines will be increasing from
one thousand to two thousand and uh the
premier just
due to the nature of the event he did
not take questions but we are being told
he will be responding to reporters
tomorrow
morning donna all right chris tadao in
calgary tonight thank you
well nova scotia has hit another record
for new covid 19 cases the province is
reporting 153
new infections today and two more deaths
those two people died
in their homes and the province is now
waiving ambulance fees for those
who have covered 19 symptoms so no one
hesitates
about getting to the hospital nova
scotia's top covid19 critical care
doctor warns icus in halifax
could approach capacity by mid-may a
second healthcare team from newfoundland
and labrador has arrived in
ontario
they'll be helping out in covid 19 hot
spots three doctors and four nurses will
be working on the front lines in
brampton ontario where case numbers
and hospitalizations are surging
another senior member of the canadian
military is facing allegations of
misconduct this time it's a lieutenant
colonel in charge
of the canadian forces school of
military intelligence
and as michael couture reports in this
global news exclusive
opposition parties are hammering the
liberal government over its handling of
what is
an institutional crisis and i am major
rafael ghee from shikutsumi quebec
an intelligence officer currently
serving at the kenyan forces school of
major intelligence a rising star in the
canadian military
rafael gaye now lieutenant colonel has
since been promoted to commandant of the
canadian forces school
of military intelligence but global news
has learned gay
was temporarily reassigned last week and
is under investigation
for alleged misconduct the department of
national defense wouldn't confirm
whether the allegations are sexual in
nature
but said in a statement quote
allegations were brought forward by a
single
third-party complainant and refer to
different incidents
that could be possible breaches of
conduct at this point
military police are not part of the
investigation
gay has been reassigned to another
position within the military's
intelligence division
the difficult portion is that there will
always be missing pieces of the puzzle
gay is just the latest senior officer in
the armed forces
under investigation for alleged
misconduct
did katie telford sit on the general
vance
allegations opposition parties continue
to hammer the government over who knew
what about
allegations of sexual misconduct against
former chief of the defense staff
general jonathan vance vance has denied
all
allegations of inappropriate behavior
and now the conservatives are linking
what they call
liberal inaction on the allegations
facing vance
to the trial of the former vice chief of
the defense staff
vice admiral mark norman did his chief
of staff sit
on allegations against the chief of
defense staff to further
the norman prosecution it's amazing to
watch the leader of the official
opposition try to twist himself in
knots to try and prosecute some sort of
conspiracy theory
meanwhile survivors of sexual misconduct
hope all of this political posturing
will one day result in meaningful reform
of the military and its culture michael
couture global news
ottawa a commuter train overpass
collapses in mexico city
coming up why some residents believe
this was a disaster
waiting to happen
this terrifying scene is from mexico
city an elevated metro train line
collapsed there at least 24 people are
known to have died
nearly 80 others are injured it happened
late last night the packed commuter
train plunging onto a busy boulevard
below
the track opened less than a decade ago
mexico's president is vowing to hold an
inquiry
as jackson proskow reports it's one of
the city's newest subway lines and there
have been allegations of poor design
and construction the collapse happened
without warning
sending the elevated train plunging onto
the busy street below
security cameras captured the exact
moment just as a train
passed witnesses on board say it
happened so fast there was barely time
to scream
dozens were killed instantly including
children many more
badly injured rescuers dug through the
twisted metal and piles of concrete
searching for victims
while the train dangled precariously
christian osorio came to the site to
find his sister
all he had was a picture on his phone
and hope
that she would be found by light of day
a crane hoisted away the damaged rail
cars as the search for victims continued
calls for an independent investigation
and accountability are growing louder
the mexican people must know the whole
truth said mexico's president
nothing will be hidden from them
mexico city's metro is one of the
busiest in the world
the collapse happened on line 12 the
newest line which has been plagued by
allegations of shoddy design and
construction since it opened
those who live nearby say they would see
the support column
shake every time a train passed
until the investigations and appropriate
tests are concluded we won't know what
caused this
said this rescue worker as grief turns
to
anger authorities are still struggling
to identify the victims and notify
families mexico is in mourning and
looking for answers
jackson prosco global news
ahead it takes a rocket scientist or two
for spacex to celebrate
star wars
well in case no one's told you yet it is
star wars day and spacex celebrated with
a rocket launch
a reused falcon 9 rocket named after the
film's starship
millennium falcon blasted off from
florida's kennedy space center
it sent 60 starlink internet satellites
into low earth orbit
the plan is to launch thousands of them
and provide high-speed internet service
to almost
every corner of the globe by 2022
pretty cool about 90 million people from
the u.s gulf coast to the northeast
are in the path of a deadly outbreak of
storms now in its third day
as many as four tornadoes plowed through
texas mississippi and georgia on monday
leaving a trail of destruction
three people were killed by falling
trees tornadoes and severe thunderstorm
warnings are in effect and 12 million
people are under
flash flood watches police in new york
city are searching for a suspect after a
horrible assault on two asian women
it was caught on surveillance camera and
a warning the video is disturbing
police say the person approached the
women asked them to remove their masks
and
attack them with a hammer it happened on
a midtown manhattan street
one woman suffered a deep cut to her
head and was treated in the hospital
the victim told nbc news she's lived in
new york for two years and has never
faced anything like this
new york has had for a 45 percent
increase in reported hate crimes
targeting people
of asian descent late last month a 61
year old
chinese man was seriously injured and
put into a medically induced coma
he was hit and viciously stomped on
during an unprovoked attack
the man's niece says it happened while
he was collecting bottles and cans to
support his family
after losing his job because of coven
19. the suspect
in that case has been arrested and
charged with attempted murder
next the tech savvy canadians who did in
a few hours what the government couldn't
get done
in weeks
developing and testing safe and
effective vaccines for covid19 happened
in record time
an amazing accomplishment for scientists
delivering those vaccines to people is
turned out to be almost as complicated
many canadians have been pulling their
hair out searching for appointments
government-run websites haven't always
made it easy
so a pair of tech developers in ontario
took matters into their own hands
and as mike delay explains they created
their own system
to beat the system in theory this
shouldn't be so hard
open up a government website input some
data and get an appoint
what no appointments when ontario
premier doug
ford got his shot he proclaimed how easy
it was to get the vaccine
so ontarians went online and waited if
being number 210
112 in line wasn't depressing enough
how about a vaccination date of february
2023
was there frustration oh yeah lots of it
so i got through with my local hospital
and was given a time and a date
says quite clearly your appointment is
confirmed
but they didn't give me a location and
i've yet to receive the follow-up text
or email
so what do i do for context there's a
lot of moving parts to rolling out a
vaccine
supply issues aside for every shelter
pharmacy
pop-up or hospital there's a booking
site now add language
cultural or technological barriers to
the equation
in ottawa a number of community groups
saw the connection between confusion
and vaccine hesitancy and began going
door to door
you know we had a clinic in a common
room and a high-rise apartment
and we easily booked 150 people and we
had 300 more that were ready and willing
and so we're excited to learn that our
community wants the vaccine
and that they're just looking for an
access point the u.s tried to simplify
its approach by launching a texting tool
to connect all those loose ends and when
a few global news reporters tweeted
about it
toronto engineer zane manji took note
you know like how hard would it be for
to actually build something like this
so he and a friend went to work and in
under two hours they built a program to
simplify something
that should have been simple all along
text a number
get a location in ontario and now bc
i don't know why me took might may have
taken so long to make it maybe
it just wasn't on the road map for them
actually so maybe they just didn't
decide to do it but
it's very simple honestly it's literally
like less than 100 lines of code
simple or complex all that matters is
that it works
microleg global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's here
at canada is
victoria beach a beautiful spot on the
southeastern shore
of lake winnipeg we'd love to see your
canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]